hey youtubers is charlie happy new year
so we got our first look at electra and
Punisher like our first official look at
them from daredevil season 2 so let's do
a breakdown we've already gotten the
teaser for season two like the first
teaser we'll probably get a full trailer
pretty soon too it's supposed to debut
in march according to Entertainment
Weekly they're like a little bit more
credible than a regular blog but not
quite as credible as a trade publication
so take that with a grain of salt they
dropped daredevil season one right
before avengers age of ultron came out
in May so they might just push it up a
little bit just to give people a little
bit more time to digest it before
captain america civil war starts but in
case you haven't read the comics just a
little bit of background Elektra is a
character of Greek descent who is part
of the hand organization the hand is
like the evil side of the chaste coin
now stick is part of the chase that we
have that brief scene during daredevil
season one kind of teasing their
organization the hand is just the other
side of that we only really got a teaser
for them too so I don't know if Electra
is going to be part of the hand in
daredevil season two or what her entry
into the story is going to be but the
way they're describing her in the TV
series is that she's going to be like
Matt's in the best bad girl friend a guy
could have if you don't know what the it
is there's the it'd the ego the
super-ego they're just Freudian concepts
the it is like your unbridled instinct
the super-ego is like the critical moral
side of your brain so that's almost like
the night nurse character just because
she's kind of a moral compass format and
then the ego is like the organized
realistic part which is kind of like the
Karen page character so I kind of like
how by women and Matt's life are his ego
and super-ego so Electra is just going
to be the fun side of that coin and it
at various points in the comics they've
been in relationship they've been at
each other's throats so she kind of
starts out as a villain when Frank
Miller first brings her into the comics
but then they become allies so I'm
guessing they're just gonna have a
little bit of fun with that in the TV
series she's kind of like a halfway step
to the danger zone just you know like
getting a little bit crazier having a
little bit more fun The Punisher is like
all the way to the danger zone so a big
part of the series is going to be
Daredevils moral dilemma in like how far
does he go like what kind of methods
does he use to clean up his neighborhood
he and the Punisher are doing almost the
exact same thing is just Punishers
killing every criminal he can get his
hands on so it kind of brings it full
circle back to that kingpin moment you
know during the
the middle of season one where he was
like you and I are very similar only I
do things on a scale that matters so you
clearly see the punisher here gearing up
and then kind of like butting heads with
daredevil he has I'm chained up here on
a rooftop but clearly something is going
to have to bring them together like
cattle as a relationship some bigger
threat so I'm wondering if Electra has
something to do with that because as it
stands right now they're kind of selling
Punisher is the crazy version of
daredevil Electra's kind of like the
siren singing this sweet song of danger
in his ear just like oh man this could
be so much more fun I should just
embrace my dark side but they haven't
really spent a whole lot of time talking
about what the kingpin is doing during
this series like is he still stuck in
jail is he calling the shots that's
usually what happens is like even though
he gets locked up in the comics he still
just as powerful as he was on the
outside so i'm wondering if he has
something to do with throwing Electra
into daredevils path but we'll see there
have been like various associations
between Marvel's criminal organizations
like the kingpin has been associated
with the hand I don't know if the TV
series is going to go with a very comic
book version of Elektra they took a lot
of visual cues from Man Without Fear
during season one but they didn't do Man
Without Fear as a storyline Electra was
actually a big part of that it's a good
story to read if you want a good Electra
story but if you do want to learn about
Electra's origin story how she became
the electric character she does have her
own self-titled miniseries you might be
able to find it on Marvel unlimited but
you might have to buy it on comixology
but let me know what your most hype
about per season 2 and what do you think
is going to happen to bring the Punisher
and daredevil together or do you think
that's not going to happen at all do you
think they'll end things like Captain
America and Iron Man during civil war
like they'll just draw a line in the
sand and be like we're never gonna agree
on this so let's just go our own
separate ways and do our own thing i
feeI feel like daredevil wouldn't be
able to walk away from that like he
would know that the punisher is killing
people and have to stop him so something
has got to happen with the Punishers arc
because he has got 0 chill and the
really awesome thing if you guys didn't
know this apparently John burnt those
performances the punisher has been so
amazing that netflix and Marvel want to
green-light a Punisher series I don't
know if that's going to end up happening
they might wait till after season 2
premieres to talk more about what's
going on with that just because they
want to promote daredevil before they
promote a Punisher series but I think
that would be awesome Punisher would be
perfect for Netflix just super graphic
super hardcore
and a lot of you are still asking about
like what's going on with the netflix
characters in civil war there's already
way too many characters in civil war
right now so I know I don't think
they'll be able to accommodate anything
that's going on in the Netflix series
they might reference it briefly but in
terms of crossover the closest we'll
probably get is some jessica jones
crossover like we got a little bit of
daredevil crossover at the end of
jessica jones just spoiler alert for
jessica jones if you haven't watched it
yet there's a night nurse crossover but
there's no daredevil crossover like no
official daredevil crossover so I'm
guessing it's going to be the same deal
with jessica jones crossing over with
daredevil season 2 and in Luke Cage to
now Luke Cage season 1 will premiere
later this year so I think it's more
likely that we get some more references
to luke cage but hopefully we'll see
some jessica jones in there too just as
a point of reference though like i know
you know there's always the question
about like where things are happening in
New York daredevil is Hell's Kitchen
jessica jones is also Hell's Kitchen
Luke Cage is supposed to take place a
little further north and harlem so it's
actually pretty likely that jessica
jones would run into daredevil at some
point if she's around at night all the
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything i'll be doing more daredevil
videos as we get closer to the season 2
premiere and also there is a captain
america 75th anniversary special on the
19th of this month it's the same day
that the flash comes back DC is doing
this huge Suicide Squad Batman V
Superman Wonder Woman special there's a
whole bunch of stuff happening on the
19th so i'll be doing videos for all
that stuff it's going to be awesome what
you guys wait for everything to post you
can click here for my daredevil season
to playlist I've done a whole bunch of
Netflix videos and you can click here
for the legends of tomorrow Boba Fett
trailer that I just posted thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five happy new year I will see you guys
in 2016
you